every day one hundred and women of the
world art in the air partner by family
members in europe one in three women and
sepyc team or physical or sexual by lynch
bat only the eren percent of those case
when reporting
in europe for women banking on line
y costillar women say about violence more
stop and we can't stop it together mon
amour women to take the streets the
british and hate of march
klein for dry rights and men email ario
inning and with his thesis of the person in charge
of haiti bags we need european  loud
place formerly freedom and integrity
that is why we are strongly fusion by
the ratification ap istanbul convention
ago first step for european legislation
things clouds loading let's go see if they
are mini women of all saints taking the
spirits we have already exit change in
the mental and  now i need to translate
even a jean claud to see that this is
no longer the fight for the feminist fip
says to be global movement the know and
will be wild west of south gate  of marks
and let it keep the faith